[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what is this place it's the everything
factory silly
it's good to see jose
yeah man really good hey i i wanted to
tell you because we haven't had a chance
to speak face to face how good you are
in wolf boy man your your performance is
really good i thought that went very
well you too locked craft was absolutely
incredible why that's brilliant
so there's some pretty cool questions
they've printed on these nifty wolf boy
cards should we dive into these oh yeah
i have some too we're going on an
adventure what is imagination in your
eyes my mom was just reminding me that
she used to find me playing
alone in my room with all kinds of just
made up characters and stories and stuff
and she would ask me what i was doing
and i would say i'm playing with my
imagination that was not the answer i
was expecting
what do you do to get your creative
juices flowing i just like sitting down
in my armchair and just
staring at a drawing pad thinking
what can i draw
what could be cool so you draw i didn't
know this about you yeah i like to draw
quite frequently it's pretty much the
best way to
get what
you see in your mind out yeah
if that makes sense that makes perfect
sense it's it's one of the creative
skills i've i've always wanted to spend
more time with
i see we have some work to do what is an
idea that no one else has come up with
yet oh oh i have an idea great a time
traveling elevator
or a magical slide it's a clock that can
rewind time so if you miss your alarm
you can just pull back the clock handle
and rewind time so you never end up
being late i need that for sure
such little respect for time
what's the strangest dream you've ever
had i was in the ocean
and for some reason i could just tell i
was a fish yet i still had human arms
and legs
and then i found some other fish and
then i started talking to them for some
reason do you remember the conversations
it sounded like english but
for some reason everyone else was
speaking
in
like just they were just going
i don't even know how that happened it
was so weird
it's all a dream
how much fun was it playing professor
loxcraft i had so much fun playing
luxcraft cool as an actor one of the big
thrills for me is getting to play
somebody that's different from myself
the lux craft is just like big guy with
a huge purple beard and he can do magic
and he's so wise be one with the wisps
let them connect to your creativity over
the course of playing him i sort of
found things about him like oh actually
that's sort of like me being an artist
is sort of like being a wizard in
certain ways i knew it i
knew it
when people watch wolf boy in the
everything factory what is it that you
hope
they get out of it
one of the best parts about playing
sprout was the message he was bringing
out to people which is do not let your
fears control what you do and i found
that very helpful just be yourself and
make us proud okay
it's a real pleasure talking to you yeah
it was a absolutely amazing finally
going to meet you i hope to see you
again soon all right thanks archie good
talking to you bye joseph
[Music]